— Sie [Die Russen] gingen davon aus,
dass sie hier mit Blumen empfangen würden.
Sie haben gesucht, wo die Blumen sind.
— Wie haben Sie es geschafft,
Widerstand zu leisten?
— Durch den Willen Gottes und nach Plan.
— Die Stadt passt sich an,
aber die Stadt wird niemandem
etwas verzeihen.
— Wir hatten hier ein Lenin-Denkmal.
Es wurde entfernt, jetzt sind da Steine.
— Wir hatten eine alte Brücke.
Jetzt wird eine neue gebaut.
— Alle haben angefangen,
Gefrierschränke auszuleeren,
wir hatten Garnelen, Lachs.
— Da waren wir glücklich,
weil wir zusammen waren,
weil wir überlebt haben.
— Die Russen fragten, ob wir viele Nazis haben.
Und wir so: „Wenn die „Nazis“ diejenigen sind,
die für die Ukraine sind, dann gibt es viele.“
— Oksana, ich grüße Sie.
Wir sind bereits hier angekommen.
— Ja, ja.
— Ich sehe Euch.
— Ihr hättet dorthin fahren sollen,
ihr seid falsch abgebogen..
Okay, kein Thema.
— Wir haben eine Abkürzung genommen.
— Alles gut.
Schauen Sie, Da war nämlich ein Luftangriff.
Das wollte ich Euch zeigen.
— Krass.
— Hier war der erste Einschlag und dort der zweite.
Das ist so schrecklich.
Da gibt es noch eins, und da noch eins.
Es waren vier Raketeneinschläge,
alle an derselben Stelle.
— Und wie viel davon traf die Wohnhäuser?
— Es gab hier sehr viele Angriffe, wir wurden
beschossen aus allen möglichen Waffen:
Panzer, Raketensysteme und vieles mehr.
Alles flog Richtung Tschernihiw.
Aber unsere Jungs wehrten vieles ab,
vieles wurde abgeschossen.
Unsere Jungs sind echt gut.
Unsere Tschernihiw-Kämpfer.
Wir danken ihnen und wir verneigen uns tief.
Weil sie es nicht zugelassen haben, dass
die Feinde in die Stadt eingedrungen sind.
Unsere Stadt ist nicht wie Mariupol
oder Butscha.
Versteht Ihr?
Deshalb verneigen wir
uns einfach vor ihnen.
Sie sind Helden, sie sind
schon jetzt Helden für uns.
Versteht Ihr das?
In unserer Nähe gab es eine Anlage —
eine Art Flugabwehrkanone,
ich weiß nicht genau, was es war,
aber es machte riesigen Lärm.
Als wir hier Panzer stehend hatten,
waren wir sehr glücklich,
denn das waren unsere Jungs,
und wir hatten vor nichts Angst.
Aber als sie sich ein wenig
zurückgezogen haben,
weil die Russen stark vorrückten,
herrschte etwa zwei Stunden lang
so eine ernste Stille,
es war in der Nacht vom 5. auf 6. März.
Mein Mann und ich sahen uns an,
wir schliefen damals im Keller,
und wir wussten, dass etwas nicht stimmte.
Als die Russen dann von Uljaniwka
aus anfingen, uns zu beschiessen,
sie kamen fast bis Nowoseliwka,
und begannen, wie die Irren zu schiessen!
Alle fünf Minuten gab es
zwei oder drei Explosionen.
Es dauerte ungefähr vier Stunden.
Ich hatte nicht einmal die Kraft,
das alles zu ertragen.
Mein Mann sagt: „Du bist
einfach ohnmächtig geworden.
Ich habe nur aufgepasst,
dass du überlebst
und keinen Herzinfarkt oder
Schlaganfall erleidest”.
Seht Ihr? Alle Häuser...
Wenn man von vorne schaut,
sieht das Haus noch ok aus,
aber von hinten ist es völlig zerstört.
Wowa! Wowa!
Sie sind nicht mehr da, die Jungs
sind irgendwohin gegangen.
Seht Ihr? Hier lebten Familien.
Ein Haus war hier, hier das zweite Haus,
da – ein drittes und ein viertes.
Dieses Haus ist niedergebrannt,
dieses hier ist abgebrannt.
Kleine Kinder lebten hier.
Eine vollständige Familie.
Nichts mehr ist erhalten geblieben,
alles liegt in Trümmern.
All dies explodierte und brach auseinander.
Sie saßen hier im Keller.
Die Kinder hatten große Angst.
Als wir die Kinder rausgeholt haben
gingen sie durch diese Tür hinaus,
dann weinten und schrien sie so sehr,
dass ich mich ganz schlecht fühlte.
Das war ein echter Horror,
ich kann das gar nicht beschreiben.
Man holt das Kind heraus,
aber es hatte Angst,
nach draußen zu gehen,
weil überall Explosionen zu hören waren.
Ich habe nur gebetet,
dass nichts explodieren würde,
während wir diese Kinder rausholen.
Dort wären sie in Sicherheit,
aber wir nehmen sie weg, versteht Ihr?
Sie könnten jeden Moment sterben.
Mein Mann sagte mir immer:
„Oksana, es wird Krieg geben!
Oksana, es wird Krieg geben!”
Und ich antwortete immer:
“Schau, wenn es anfängt,
dann denken wir darüber nach,
aber jetzt möchte ich richtig leben,
jeden Tag vollständig erleben,
in vollem Umfang leben.
Ich möchte keinen einzigen Tag verlieren”.
Und eines Morgens springt er
aus dem Bett und sagt:
„Oksana, Krieg!”
Ich wache auf und denke:
„Nein, das kann nicht sein
das kann nicht wahr sein.“.
Er rennt zum Fenster, öffnet es,
und da sind schon die ersten Explosionen
und Sirenengeräusche...
Ich blieb stehen, ich war so geschockt!
Wir sind weggelaufen.
— Wann seid ihr zurückgekommen?
— Mein Gott, ich erinnere mich
nicht mehr an die Tage...
Ich weiß nicht einmal,
welcher Tag heute ist.
Als wir ankamen und als ich das sah...
Diese Straße...
Hier, schaut mal: Hier hinter uns und
dort hinter uns ist die Straße…
Alles dort ist bombardiert und niedergebrannt.
Wir gehen jetzt in den Garten.
Und hier war offenbar Gottes Hand im Spiel:
Er bedeckte uns wie unter einer Kuppel.
Diese Häuser scheinen
abgedeckt worden zu sein...
Ja, das Dach hat ein wenig gelitten:
hier und da ein wenig,
aber die Häuser blieben unversehrt, wisst Ihr?
Es gibt einen Ort, an den man
zurückkehren kann.
Aber die anderen Leute haben nichts.
Das war meine Werkstatt.
Mittlerweile haben wir hier auch ein Lager.
Der Schlag kam von der anderen Seite.
Und hier waren wir im Keller...
Ich werde euch jetzt reinbringen
und es Euch zeigen.
Wir haben die Matratze bereits weggebracht.
Dort im Keller saßen wir und versteckten uns
vom 24. Februar bis zur Nacht
vom 5. auf den 6. März.
Wir waren so viele Tage im Keller.
Wir gingen nur ganz kurz raus.
Sonst waren wir die ganze Zeit im Keller.
Denn sobald man rauskommt, wird geschossen.
Und dann noch die Trümmerteile…
Als wir mit dem Auto flüchten wollten,
durchschlugen Trümmerteil
die Windschutzscheibe.
Wir haben durch ein Wunder überlebt.
Ich weiß nicht wie.
Deshalb ist dies Teil unseres Lebens.
Und wisst Ihr, als wir in diesem Keller waren,
dachte ich: „Ich brauche wahrscheinlich
nichts mehr.”
Denn all das ist was wir,
wie Ameisen,
bringen, holen, sammeln, aneignen...
Das Geschirr, die Schränke, die coolen Autos —
das alles braucht man nicht.
Dort waren wir glücklich,
weil wir zusammen waren, weil wir lebten.
Wir waren uns dessen so bewusst,
dass ich es Ihnen mit Worten
gar nicht erklären kann.
Das ist mein Lieblingsgarten.
— War dort die Explosion?
Ja. Diese Explosion zerstörte
das gesamte Gewächshaus,
es ist komplett hin.
Das ganze Glas, alles ist kaputt.
Wir saßen zu diesem Zeitpunkt im Keller.
Es war so schrecklich, wisst Ihr?
Wir sitzen und ich höre
dieses Flugzeuggeräusch,
und ich habe so eine Riesenangst...
Ich kann es nicht einmal erklären.
Der ganze Körper zieht sich zusammen,
und wenn man so eine Explosion hört,
hat man Pudding in den Beinen.
Ihr könnt hier noch nicht hingehen,
hier wurden die Minen noch nicht geräumt.
Und jetzt werden wir von
dieser Seite reingehen.
Schaut mal: Das sind Balkone,
und das war früher meine Wohnung,
Wir wohnten hier im zweiten Stock.
Da ist mein ganzes Leben.
Einfach schrecklich.
Es war mal eine Straße,
jetzt gibt es keine Straße mehr.
Seht Ihr? Alles ist voll mit Schutt...
Das war eine Straße.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich hierherkomme,
kann ich nicht anders als weinen.
Es wurde so viel Kummer verursacht.
Versteht Ihr, die Leute,
die den Krieg überlebten,
werden niemals so sein wie früher.
Man ist ruhig, man versteht, dass
es keine Explosion mehr gibt,
dass nicht mehr geschossen wird.
Doch irgendwo ertönt ein Geräusch,
z. B. ein Topf ist umgefallen,
und wir alle erstarren für einen Moment.
Es dauert eine oder zwei Sekunden,
bis einem klar wird,
dass es keine Explosion ist,
dass es kein Luftangriff ist.
Ich denke, es wird sehr lange dauern.
Das ist ein Nachkriegssyndrom,
dieser Horror wird noch
lange bestehen bleiben.
Es kamen keine Lebensmittel hierhin,
die Leute waren hungrig.
Das Erste, was ich hierher gebracht habe,
waren Brötchen.
Wie man sie aß…
Entschuldigung.
[weint]
Ich sah es alles und verstand,
dass ich nicht einfach
nichtstuend sitzen kann.
Ich schrieb einen Post auf
Facebook und man fing an,
uns humanitäre Hilfsgüter zu bringen.
Und gestern sah ich,
dass es Konserven gibt,
dass Kondensmilch und
Schokoladenmilch aus Kyjiw gebracht wurde.
Vor dem Krieg haben die Einheimischen
so etwas nicht gesehen, nicht gegessen,
Weil sie all diese Häuser
mit eigenen Mitteln
gebaut haben, genau wie ich,
versteht Ihr?
Entschuldigung.
Und sobald einem klar wird,
dass keiner helfen wird,
dann muss man sich selber helfen.
Geht also einfach durch und schaut mal,
was verfügbar ist. Ich zeige es Euch,
wir vergeben alles.
Wir haben Konserven und Schokolade.
Schaut es Euch mal an:
hier ist Kondensmilch.
Das alles geben wir den Menschen.
Kommt rein, ich führe Euch herum.
Das ist das Zimmer meines Kindes.
All diese Möbel waren gestern nass,
das Wasser floss einfach über sie hinweg.
Der Teppich ist nass...
Seht Ihr die Decke? -
da fließt alles durch.
Ich kann hier nichts hinstellen.
Das ist mein Wohnzimmer...
Das fährt weg... Schaut mal,
wenn die großen Lieferungen kommen,
poste ich alles auf Facebook...
Alles geht an Waisenhäuser.
Gestern kam zum ersten Mal eine Frau,
deren Haus niedergebrannt ist,
Sie kommt herein, sieht so verwirrt aus...
Ich sage: „Was brauchen Sie?
Es gibt alles”.
Sie: „Alles? Wirklich alles?“
Ich sage: „Alles. Sogar Schuhe,
Kleidung und Teller - alles.
Und alles Mögliche zum Essen”.
Sie steht da weinend und sagt,
„Ich hatte alles, ich brauchte nichts,
Aber jetzt weiß ich nicht einmal,
was ich nehmen soll”.
Sie ist verwirrt, sie sagt:
„Ich weiß nicht, was ich nehmen soll”.
Sie sehen, das ist alles geladen,
heute werden wir alles sortieren.
Kommt mal hierher.
Wir laden alles ab und
geben den Menschen.
warme Decken, seht Ihr?
Jetzt gibt es alles.
Die Kinder kommen zurück.
Seht Ihr?
Das ist Natalotschka.
meine Assistentin hier in Novoseliwka.
Sie betreut die humanitäre Hilfe.
Man hat das hierhin gebracht
und das Auto ausgeladen.
Es gibt einfach noch keine Leute,
die Leute wissen es nicht.
Sind das die Ersten, die
hier waren, sag  mir?
Wenn hier humanitäre Hilfe ankommt,
versammeln sich viele Menschen.
Gegen 11-12 Uhr ungefähr.
Die Leute bringen alles mit.
Ihr könnt sehen, was man
dieses Mal mitgebracht hat.
— Eine Pfanne für mich.
Ich bin sehr glücklich, unendlich glücklich.
— Ich werde mehr mitbringen,
mehr Geschirr.
— Gab es irgendwo hier eine Bratpfanne?
— Ist schon weg.
— Ich werde euch noch
mehr Geschirr bringen.
Sie werden sehen, das Geschirr
kommt noch, es ist noch nicht da.
Alles wird kommen.
Und hier ist sie, schaut mal. Seht Ihr?
Der Mensch ist mit einer gebrauchten
Pfanne glücklich, versteht Ihr?
— Wieder einmal finden wir
eine Bestätigung dafür,
dass die Ukrainer nicht darauf warten,
dass jemand etwas für sie tut.
Es spielt keine Rolle, ob es darum geht,
mit bloßen Händen Widerstand zu leisten,
oder die Heimatstadt, die Straße
oder das Haus wieder aufzubauen.
Jeder versucht, seinen Beitrag zu leisten.
Es scheint mir, dass diese Invasion
zum Impuls, damit ein des Phönix aus
der Asche steigt, zur einer neuen Geburt.
Und dass sich unser Land wiedererneut
und sich in alle Richtungen entwickelt.
Mir ist noch ein weiteres Detail aufgefallen,
dass jeder unbedingt mit uns reden wollte.
Das heißt, als sie die Kamera sahen,
jedes Mal, wenn jemand auf sie zukam,
und beobachtete, was wir taten,
war interessiert
und versuchte, irgendwie
mit uns zu reden.
Sie waren daran interessiert, mit
anderen Menschen zu sprechen,
die von anderen Orten kamen,
um zu hören, was in Kyjiw
und anderswo passiert.
Es ist auch sehr wichtig,
an andere Orte zu gehen.
Die Menschen, die gelitten haben, verstehen,
dass sie nicht allein sind,
dass sie unterstützt werden,
dass die Trauer nicht nur ihr Heim,
sondern die ganze Ukraine erreicht hat.
Dass die Ukraine ein eingenständiger
und vereinter Staat ist und nicht das,
was russische Propagandisten
uns aufzuzwingen versuchen.
— Olesja!
— Freut mich!
— Ebenfalls!
— Oleg, Roma, Kostya.
Ich sah eine Anzeige eines Mannes,
der schrieb, dass er Tulpen für
einen geringen Betrag verkaufe.
Ich fragte, wie viel sie kosten.
Und ich bot ihm an,
mit dem Verkauf zu helfen,
da das Geschäft schlecht lief.
Sie waren dort für jeweils
sieben Hrywnja [ca. 20 Cent].
Und mir kam die Idee, Tulpen zu liefern.
Ich bin mit den Tulpen drei
Tage lang gefahren.
Dann erfuhr ich, dass der Mann während
der Besatzung in Lukaschiwka war.
Das heißt, sie sind weggefahren
und gerieten in die Okkupation.
Kurz gesagt, ich habe alle Tulpen verkauft.
— Wurden sie hauptsächlich von
denen bestellt, die weggefahren sind
und den anderen eine Freude machen wollten?
— Ja ja. Eine Frau weinte so sehr,
dass ich nicht wusste,
wie ich sie beruhigen sollte.
Doch dann schrieb ihre Tochter:
„Ich bin sehr dankbar,
dass Sie so eine Idee hatten“.
Sie wollte die Tulpen nicht
nehmen und weinte.
Und ich sage: „Alles ist gut.“
Und sie verteilte diese Tulpen
im ganzen Haus.
Sie lebt in einem zweistöckigen Gebäude,
und sie ging durch die Wohnungen.
Außerdem habe ich am ersten Tag
eine Gruppe auf Facebook gegründet
um uns gegenseitig zu helfen.
Weil ich verstanden habe – und ich wollte
es den Menschen vermitteln –
dass es nicht genug Freiwillige für alle gibt,
die Stadt ist zu groß.
Und es ist einfach unmöglich,
von einem Bezirk zum anderen zu rennen.
Es ist einfach unmöglich.
Aber die Suppe, die man
selbst gekocht hat,
einem Nachbarn oder Nachbarin
vorbeizubringen —
das kann jeder.
Man sagte, ein Drittel der Stadtbewohner
sei weggefahren.
Und noch viele Menschen sind geblieben,
die sogar aus der eigenen Wohnung
nicht rausgehen konnten.
Das war der Sinn dieser Gruppe.
Ich habe dort sehr lange kämpfen müssen,
denn alle fragten: „Gib mir
die Kontakte der Freiwilligen.“
Ich habe allen erklärt:
„Suchen Sie keine Freiwilligen,
schauen Sie sich um, finden Sie
hilfsbereite Nachbarn.
Seien Sie froh, jemandem
geholfen zu haben.
Es ist eine echte Freude, wenn man
jemandem geholfen hat.
Es gibt eine lustige Geschichte darüber,
als es in der ganzen Stadt keinen Strom gab.
— Nachdem das Kraftwerk gesprengt wurde?
— Ja.
Und da Leute die Schlüssel eines Nachbarn,
eines Freundes hatte,
begannen alle, die Gefrierschränke
auszuräumen,
in denen sich jede Menge
Lebensmittel befanden.
Also hatten wir Garnelen, Lachs...
Diese Facebook-Gruppe existiert noch.
Alles fing damit an, dass Leute sich austauschten,
was sie an Lebensmitteln haben.
Es gab manchmal solche Momente,
wo Leute in Panik schrieben:
„Wir wurden alleine gelassen“,
„Tschernihiw wurde alleine gelassen“.
Und ich war sehr froh, dass ich
die Gruppe administrierte,
denn so konnte ich alle
diese Posts löschen.
Ich habe all diese Leute verbannt,
weil es unerträglich war.
Mir wurde auch viel erzählt,
dass die Leute ihre
Nachbarn kennenlernten,
über die sie davor nichts wussten.
Als es kein Wasser mehr gab, fingen
die Nachbarn an, miteinander zu reden,
„Wasser gibt es da“,
„eine Pumpe arbeitet dort“.
Das vereint sehr.
Es ist natürlich traurig, es ist eine
traurige Geschichte im Allgemeinen,
aber ich viel gesehen, wie sich
Leute zusammengetan haben.
— Warum haben die Russen es nicht geschafft, Tschernihiw einzunehmen?
— Weil Tschernihiw gekämpft hat.
Und die Stadt war auf den
Sieg ausgerichtet, glaube ich.
— Haben sie mit Absicht auf
das Hotel „Ukraine“ geschossen?
— Ja. Haben Sie etwa nicht gesehen?
Es gab eine Reportage,
— Eine Ausbildungsbasis ausländischer Söldner
durch einen präzisen Raketenangriff
zerstört wurde.
Das sind die Folgen: das ehemalige
Hotel „Ukraine“ in Tschernihiw,
in dem Söldner untergebracht waren,
die aus dem Ausland kamen,
um zu kämpfern.
Das Hauptquartier der
sogenannten Fremdenlegion
funktionierte nicht lange.
— Zuerst dachte ich, dass es
wegen dem Namen „Ukraine“ war,
sie wollten es wohl symbolisch tun.
Aber in Wirklichkeit nicht.
Tatsächlich haben sie eine sehr lustige
Geschichte darüber gedreht,
wie dort angeblich Söldner waren,
als ob hier ausländische Söldner
ausgebildet worden wären.
— Mein Name ist Bogdan.
— Natalja. Freut mich.
Wir hatten hier ein Lenin-Denkmal.
Es wurde abgerissen, jetzt sind dort Steine.
Wahrscheinlich ist dies das beste Denkmal,
das anstelle Lenins sein kann.
Nur Steine ​​und Eisen.
— Jetzt werden die Lenins
im Süden aufgestellt.
So kleine wie Zwerge,
haben Sie gesehen?
— Nein, ich habe heute gesehen,
wie der Kopf der russischen Arbeiters
des Denkmals „Freundschaft der Völker“
runterfiel.
Das war sehr symbolisch.
Ewig war die Freundschaft doch nicht:
Der kräftige uklrainische Kosake
steht immer noch, der Russe aber nicht.
Das ist eigentlich sehr gut.
Ich wohne auf der anderen
Seite des Marktes
und mein Mann fängt
nachts an zu zittern.
Er rennt herum, schaut hin und sagt:
„Ich schaue aus dem Fenster,
da fliegt mir eine Rakete ins Gesicht.
Und dieses Gebäude wurde getroffen.
Wir können es hier nicht sehen,
aber von der Rückseite des Hauses
gibt es ein riesiges Loch.
Und dies war der letzte
starke Bombenangriff.
Der Markt stand in Flammen,
alles hat dort gebrannt.
Unser Postamt wurde auch
in Mitleidenschaft gezogen.
Ehrlich gesagt, ist es gut,
dass es nachts war,
denn hier haben die Leute Verlängerungskabel
hingelegt und ihre Handys aufgeladen.
In den Höfen gab es Generatoren,
aber hier hat man alles mit
Verlängerungskabeln gemacht.
Es gab dort immer viele Menschen.
Die Anspannung ist immer noch da und sie
hat, ehrlich gesagt, keinesfalls angenommen.
Wir verstehen unsere Nähe zu der Grenze.
Es ist zu früh, um sich zu entspannen.
Man muss zwar weiterleben,
aber immer noch bereit sein,
jederzeit reagieren zu können.
— Warum gab Tschernihiw nicht auf?
— Man sagt, dass wir eine
coole Armee haben,
aber ich sage, dass wir auch coole Mädels haben,
die hier in der Stadt helfen..
Die meisten Männer sind entweder
bei der territorialen Verteidigung sind
oder sind vorwiegend Fahrer.
Und die Mädchen beschäftigen sich
mit den anderen Sachen:
Lebensmittel finden, Essen kochen,
Medikamente verteilen, viel verhandeln.
Das heißt, etwas zusammen machen.
Ich verstehe, dass viele Menschen Angst hatten,
sie saßen in Luftschutzbunkern..
Aber diese Gruppe von Menschen,
die keine Angst hatten,
natürlich hatten sie Angst,
aber sie waren aktiv,
sie nahmen diese moralische
und physische Last auf sich.
Ich glaube, die Jungs haben es begriffen,
dass sie eine Rückendeckung haben
und dass es jemanden gibt,
für den sie zu kämpfen haben.
— Wie wird sich Tschernihiw
nach dem Sieg verändern?
— Wenn es sich ändert,
dann nicht so schnell,
wie wir es gerne hätten.
Weil es notwendig ist, alles zu erfassen.
Denn selbst Leute, die hier
nicht unter Beschuss waren,
kommen zurück und verstehen nicht,
warum wir so reagieren..
Ein Lärm! Du drehst dich
zumindest um und schaust,
ob es ein Auto ist oder
ob etwas nicht stimmt.
Diejenigen, die hier waren,
etwas getan haben,
sie werden sich verändern,
das ist sicher.
Und es gibt bereits ein Verständnis davon,
das sich hier ein Kern formt.
— Ein Kern wovon?
— Von der Nation wahrscheinlich.
Einer elbstbewussten Nation,
nicht einfach von allen Menschen,
sondern bewussten Menschen,
die verstehen,
dass wir tatsächlich
in einem freien Land leben,
in einem demokratischen Land,
und unsere Meinung frei äußern können.
Wir dürfen das tun.
Wir können uns über die Amtsinhaber
lustig machen, das dürfen wir auch.
Und wir akzeptieren es als Gewöhnlich.
Trotz einiger finanzieller Probleme,
sind wir eigentlich glückliche Menschen,
weil unser Mund nicht geknebelt wird.
Ich würde mir diese schnellen Änderungen
natürlich sehr wünschen,
aber das wird sich mit der Zeit zeigen.
— Es scheint mir, dass Russland
diese Veränderungen vorantreibt.
Sie helfen uns, dies zu ändern.
— Ich sage mal ehrlich, ich bin seit Kindheit
mit Russisch aufgewachsen.
Aber das macht mich nicht zur Russin,
ich bin Ukrainerin.
Ich bin eine russischsprachige „Banderiwka“.
Und wenn man mir schreibt:
„Du weißt nicht, was da bei euch los ist,
In deinem Land wurde die Macht ergriffen”.
Ich antworte: „Wer hat sie denn ergriffen?“
Ich sage: „Ich habe bei der Wahl abgestimmt,
Ich habe diejenigen gewählt,
die ich an der Macht sehen will”.
Ich habe nicht diejenigen gewählt,
die jetzt an der Macht sind.
Ich mag ihn jetzt nicht.
Ich habe für jemanden anderen abgestimmt
und ich werde dafür nicht bestraft.
Ich kann rausgehen und öffentlich sagen,
dass ich gegen den Krieg bin,
und niemand wird mich verhaften
oder etwas antun.
Ich lese die Literatur, die ich will”.
„Nein, du verstehst es nicht,
du wirst es später verstehen,
dort bei dir sind Nazis”.
Ich sage: „Wo?“
Oder die andere Frage:
„Habt ihr viele Nazis?“
„Wenn die Nazis diejenigen sind,
die für die Ukraine sind,
dann ja, es gibt viele“.
Aber Faschisten haben wir keine.
Warum ein Russe, der Russland liebt,
ein Patriot ist,
aber ein Ukrainer, der die Ukraine liebt,
ist ein Nazi und ein Faschist?
Und wenn man den Russen solche Fragen stellt,
haben sie keine Argumente mehr.
Wir werden gefragt:
„Wo wart ihr acht Jahre lang im Donbas?“
Ich sage: „Warum war es dort
ruhig und friedlich,
bis ihr nicht gekommen seid?“
Das sind wirklich zombifizierte Menschen.
Ich weiß, dass sich viele für immer
mit ihren Verwandten zerstritten haben.
Es ist wahrscheinlich die
richtige Entscheidung.
— Und wahrscheinlich ist es für immer.
— Ja.
— Was sind Ihre Gefühle,
wie verändert sich Tschernihiw jetzt?
— Ich denke, die Dinge
ändern sich zum Besseren.
Das würde ich gerne glauben.
Denn schließlich kommt bei den Menschen
mehr Patriotismus auf.
Keiner sang früher das Lied „Tscherwona Kalyna“
(„Rote Drosselbeere“), jetzt kennt es jeder.
Und das ist cool, glaube ich.
Außerdem hatten wir wirklich eine
sehr alte und schäbige Brücke,
jetzt wird eine neue gebaut.
Und ich denke, dass alles
wieder aufgebaut wird.
— Und das Hotel war schon
so nicht neu, oder?
— Das Hotel wurde übrigens
sehr lange renoviert.
Kurz vor dem Krieg haben wir dort
eine Woche lang Schulungen durchgeführt,
und dort funktionierte ein Stockwerk,
das andere nicht.
Viel zu lange wurde das Hotel restauriert.
Deshalb ist es vielleicht zum besseren,
denn das neue Hotel wird modern sein.
Denn es sah immer noch
ein wenig sowjetisch aus.
Deshalb wird es meiner Meinung nach
kein Problem sein,
ein neues Hotel zu bauen.
— Kannst du mir sagen,
was für eine Apotheke das ist?
— Diese Apotheke war während des Krieges
jeden Tag geöffnet.
Eigentlich waren die anderen Apotheken zu.
Und das ist der Tatsache zu verdanken,
dass es da eine Switlana gibt,
zu der wir jetzt gehen
und alles sehen werden.
Sie erzählt uns etwas mehr.
— Guten Tag.
— Hallo.
— Oh, du bist nicht allein.
— Natürlich nicht.
— Switlana, guten Tag,
mein Name ist Bogdan.
— Ich bin Switlana, die Leiterin hier.
Wahrscheinlich war es mein Schicksal,
hier in der Apotheke zu sein.
Weil ich die Gelegenheit hatte,
Medikamente zu verwalten.
Und ohne Medikamente macht es,
wie man so sagt,
selbst in Friedenszeiten
keinen großen Spaß.
— Wie kam es zu Ihrer Entscheidung,
weiterzuarbeiten?
Weil die meisten Apotheken
geschlossen hatten, oder?
— Wissen Sie, ich hatte es an
einem Nachmittag verstanden.
Die Leute kamen herein und fragten:
„Werden Sie morgen da sein?“
Und als mein Bruder vorbeikam –
er ist auch an der Frontlinie,
verteidigt unseren Staat,
entschloss ich mich ohne Zögerung,
dass ich hier bleiben würde.
Weil meine ganze Familie,
alle meine Lieben verteidigen die Ukraine,
schützen unsere Integrität, beschützen uns.
Ich verstehe, dass ich Zivilistin bin.
Was kann ich tun?
Ich kann nur meine Unterstützung
und Hilfe anbieten.
Man schreibt das Medikament auf,
man schreibt den Barcode auf.
Den ganzen Tag schreibe ich,
schreibe und schreibe,
verstehen Sie?
Und dann— nur, wenn es Strom gibt
oder wenn ich nach einem Generator frage,
dann verbringe vier oder fünf Stunden damit,
das alles einzutippen.
Und dann ist man so erschöpft, wissen Sie...
— Switlana saß manchmal bis in die Nacht hier.
— Das sind die Quittungen... Denn es muss
doch eine Kontrolle geben.
— Haben Sie alle Zahlen?
— Stand heute ist alles gut...
— Großartig!
— In Ordnung.
Wir passen uns an.
Die Stadt passt sich an.
Nur wird die Stadt niemandem
etwas verzeihen.
Ich persönlich werde es nie verzeihen.
Weil dieser Schmerz,
den man abends sieht,
wenn ich zu den Leuten gehe,
ihre Tränen.
Besonders wenn sie ohne
Zuhause geblieben sind.
Wissen Sie, das Haus steht,
halb eingestürzt,
halb mit Folie bedeckt,
weil es gerade regnet.
Menschen schlafen in nassen Betten.
Ohne Essen, weil man muss
es erst hinbringen.
Ein alter Mann mit einem Gehstock
wird nicht ins Stadtzentrum gehen.
Nein, er wird nicht hingehen.
Und er wartet.
Er hat eine Rente, kann damit
aber nichts anfangen.
Jeder befand sich in
einer solchen Situation.
Nun, jeder passt sich an,
alles wird gut sein.
Die Hauptsache ist, dass wir nicht
unter Druck gesetzt werden.
Prinzipiell ist es auch von
dieser Seite aus möglich, aber...
— Ja.
— Ja, natürlich.
— Es ist nicht beängstigend.
— Natürlich.
— Ich bin selbst Bauingenieur seit 1966.
Ich lebe im Dorf.
Ich bin angekommen, ich schaue mal rum,
was hier so los ist.
— Alles klar.
— Da wo die Fahnen hängen,
gab es mal einen Spielplatz
für irgendwelche Jugendtreffen.
— Und das war ein Jugendzentrum?
— Ein Jugendtreff, genau.
Und es wurde wieder umgebaut.
Es gab ein Zimmer,
das ganz neu und cool war.
Dort fanden allerlei Aktivitäten
für Jugendliche statt.
Als Jugendzentrum lief es sehr gut.
— War es nachts? Hier ist jemand gestorben?
— Nein, hier ist niemand gestorben.
Die Stadtverwaltung war in der Nähe,
also vielleicht deshalb...
— Vielleicht haben sie es
nicht so präzis geschossen.
— Genau.
— Guten Tag, wir sind da.
— Guten Tag. Ich grüße Sie.
— Das ist Frau Nelya,
die Direktorin dieser Schule —
„MudrAngeliki“ („weise Engelchen“).
Sie wird mehr erzählen.
Das ist Bogdan, Leiter des Projektes „Ukrainer“.
— Freut mich.
Sagen Sie bitte, wohin gehen wir jetzt?
— Das ist der Keller der Schule.
Hier versteckten sich die Menschen
vor Artilleriefeuer und Luftangriffen.
— Wie viele Leute waren da?
— An einem der Tage zählte man
rund 215 Personen.
ber die Zahl schwankte, denn diejenigen,
die ein oder zwei Tage hier waren
und dann die Möglichkeit hatten wegzufahren,
haben wir von hier nach Kyjiw evakuiert.
Gegen Ende der Blockade von Tschernihiw
gab es hier deutlich weniger Menschen.
Ungefähr 115—120 Personen.
Es waren allerlei Leute:
von dreimonatigem Baby
bis älteren kranken Menschen.
Einige kamen allein, es gab auch Familien,
die nach dem Beschuss kamen,
als sie ihre Häuser verloren haben.
Die territoriale Verteidigung
und die Polizei wussten,
dass es hier eine Stelle gibt, eine Unterkunft,
deshalb brachten sie solche Familien zu uns.
Wir gehen jetzt in die Sporthalle.
Dort haben die Menschen geschlafen
und sich damit zugedeckt.
Alle Matten hat man benutzt, nur die reinen
Sportmatten wurden rausgebracht.
Wer konnte, hat sein Hab und Gut
aus umliegenden Häusern mitgebracht.
Und dann etwas auf die Matten draufgelegt.
Später haben wir gemeinsam mit den
Freiwilligen von Tschernihiw gearbeitet.
Die Familien, die nach den Beschüssen
hierhin gekommen sind,
hatten nur einen „Notfall-Rücksack“ dabei,
nichts mehr.
Und es kam auch vor, dass Menschen
keine Menschen mithatten,
weil sie versuchten, sich zu retten und
einfach aus ihren Häusern wegrannten.
— Was glauben Sie, warum wurden Schulen
und Krankenhäuser bombardiert?
— Sie müssen gehört haben, dass in Butscha
nicht nur Schulen bombardiert wurden,
dort wurden Lehrer aufgesucht
und erschossen.
Wenn Sie Schul- oder
Kindergartnerlehrer sind,
dann verstanden die Besatzer,
dass sie ein Erzieher sind.
Ich sage es mal ehrlich:
Das ist das Herz der Nation.
Diejenigen, die ewig Gutes und Intelligentes
den anderen beibringen.
Daher sind sie die ersten,
die ermordet werden.
Die Besatzer haben Angst
vor solchen Menschen.
Sie haben ihr System in Russland
ganz anders aufgebaut.
Auf ganz anderen Werten.
Ich würde es nicht einmal
als Werte bezeichnen.
Und das steht in krassem Widerspruch
zu unseren Werten.
Wir verstehen, dass eine völlige
Vernichtung anvisiert ist.
Unabhängig davon, ob man zu dem Militär
gehört oder ein Zivilist ist.
— Wie wird die Ukraine nach dem Sieg aussehen?
— Ich bin fest davon überzeugt,
dass die Ukraine stärker sein wird.
Die Ukraine wird völlig anders sein.
Menschen werden anders sein.
Ich bin an Ostern durch die Stadt gelaufen
und ich habe viele solche Momente gesehen,
in denen Ostertische vor dem Haus
gedeckt wurden.
Und alle Bewohner gingen hinaus,
um Ostern gemeinsam zu feiern.
Wie eine Familie.
Die Menschen sind völlig anders geworden.
Eine Größenordnung besser.
Nicht jeder schätzte diese Unabhängigkeit.
Leider kostet sie und viel Blut und Tod,
aber so wird man sie besser würdigen.
Wir engagieren uns weiterhin ehrenamtlich,
und betreuen Familien mit Kindern
im Alter bis zu drei Jahren.
Zweimal pro Woche liefern wir
Pakete in die Wohnungen:
Dazu gehören Windeln und Babynahrung,
Lebensmittel, Hygieneartikel
und alles, was nötig ist.
Und dazu noch Lebensmittel für die Mutter.
Ich muss zugeben,
dass unsere territoriale Verteidigung
uns zu Kriegsbeginn vieles beigebracht haben.
Diejenigen, die den Krieg
im Osten der Ukraine erlebt haben.
Sie versorgten uns mit Hilfe
der umliegenden Dörfer
und wir haben eine sehr enge Verbindung
zum Dorf Lukaschiwka,
das unter der Besatzung sehr gelitten hat.
Vor der Okkupation dieses Dorfes
bat der dortige Farmer,
unsere Schule mit Nahrungsmitteln
zu versorgen.
Sie lieferten sowohl Milch als auch Fleisch.
Obwohl ich fragte: „Warum muss man
Vorräte anlegen?
Vielleicht wird es irgendwo benötigt“.
Aber sie haben geantwortet:
„Warten Sie mal ab! Keine Sorge,
Sie werden viele Leute haben,
Sie müssen sie versorgen, wenn es zu
einer plötzlichen Blockade kommt.“
Und diese Reserve war im Prinzip notwendig,
denn als die Brücke zerstört wurde,
konnte die humanitäre Hilfe eine zeitlang
nicht geliefert werden.
Wir mussten irgendwie überleben,
und so haben uns diese Vorräte gerettet!
Sie werden es jetzt einfach umdrehen.
Das ist großartig!
Ganz andere Sache!
Eigentlich bin ich Lehrer.
Ich arbeite an der Schule.
Ich bin Klassenlehrer.
Meine Klasse macht Abschluss dieses Jahr.
Am 24. Februar weckte mich meine Frau,
und sagte, der Krieg hat begonnen.
Ich habe es nicht sofort verstanden,
habe mich mit kaltem Wasser gewaschen,
und mich auf die Backe geschlagen,
um aufzuwachen.
Ich habe meiner Familie geholfen zu packen.
Die Töchter waren schon gepackt.
In anderthalb Stunden verließen
meine Mädchen die Stadt,
und ich machte mich auf den Weg
zum Sammelplatz,
denn seit 2018 gehöre ich
der Territorialverteidigungsreserve an.
Damals habe ich schon verstanden,
was ich tun werde.
Leider ist nicht alles angekommen,
was ich vor dem Krieg bestellt habe.
Irgendwo liegt es in der Postfiliale.
Ob es in der Tat da ist oder nicht, weiß ich nicht,
aber ich habe es noch nicht erhalten.
— Haben Sie sich darauf vorbereitet,
dass der Krieg doch beginnt?
— Schwer zu sagen. Sie können sich doch
das Gehalt des Lehrers vorstellen, oder?
Und alles, was ich habe,
ist nicht so billig.
Das heißt, etwas gehört mir,
etwas wurde von den Jungs geschenkt,
etwas wurde von Freiwilligen mitgebracht.
Ein großes Dankeschön an sie.
Ohne sie wäre es für uns
viel schwieriger gewesen.
— Was geschah als nächstes?
Wie entstand die Territorialverteidigung
in Tschernihiw?
— Die Reservisten und die,
die schon in der Stadt waren
wurden irgendwann ab 11 Uhr als Einheiten
in die Richtungen geschickt, in denen der Feind
am schnellsten durchgedrungen ist.
Bereits am 24. Februar kam es
zu den ersten Gefechten,
den ersten Kämpfen, den ersten Verlusten.
Dieser Prozess zog sich über eine Woche hin.
Die Leute kamen, kamen und kamen,
es waren viele Leute da.
Manch einer kam mit Verständnis,
manch anderer dachte,
dass ihm ein Maschinengewehr
ausgehändigt wird,
und sein Haus zu verteidigen.
Deshalb hat hier jeder
seine eigene Geschichte.
— Wie viele Menschen sind insgesamt
der territorialen Verteidigung beigetreten?
— Sehr viel. Mehr als fünftausend,
das ist sicher.
— Reichten die Waffen aus?
— Waffen gab es für alle.
— Das größte Problem war die Munition,
Schutzwesten und Helme?
— Das bleibt auch immer noch ein Problem,
weil Schutzwesten der Klasse IV
mit Stahlplatten
und Schutzwesten der Klasse IV
mit Keramikplatten —
das sind zwei verschiedene Dinge.
Wenn man auf einer Position steht,
kann man die aus Stahl verwenden,
aber solch eine Weste ist sehr schwer
und man muss seinen Rücken schonen.
Die Keramikplatten sind viel leichter.
Alles kommt allmählich, nach und nach.
Etwas — vom Staat, etwas — von Freiwilligen,
etwas von den Jungs selbst.
Jetzt kann man selber etwas selbst kaufen,
aberdavor wurden wir fast
einen Monat lang belagert.
Ich weiß nicht, durch welches
Wunder die Freiwilligen,
die die Flüchtlinge aus der Stadt
evakuiert haben, durchgedrungen sind.
— Auch mit den Booten, oder?
— Sie waren sowohl auf Booten
als auch auf Flößen unterwegs.
Alles wurde getan,
um etwas hierher zu liefern,
denn das Kraftwerk wurde zerstört.
Auch fast alle Tankstellen
wurden beschädigt.
Und Treibstoff, Strom gab es keinen...
Mancherorts gab es noch Gas.
Die Leute versuchten,
sich irgendwie aufgewärmen.
Es fehlte immer an Schlaf und Wärme.
— Ich weiß, dass die Bewohner der
umliegenden Dörfer dabei halfen,
das Feuer auf die feindlichen Positionen
zu lenken.
— Sie meinen, sie haben uns geholfen?
— Genau.
— Natürlich haben sie geholfen.
Und nicht nur die aus den
umliegenden Dörfern,
sondern auch alle, die sich bereits
im Rücken des Feindes befanden:
Wer die Gelegenheit hatte und noch
ein paar Prozent auf dem Handy-Akku hatte.
gab alle Auskunft darüber,
wo die Russen sind,
welche Fahrzeuge gefahren werden,
in welche Richtung und zu welcher Zeit.
— Inwiefern half die Information,
wie viele und wo die feindlichen
Fahrzeuge vorbeigefahren sind?
— Es hilft selbstverständlich sehr, es hilft.
Wir verstehen, wie viele Fahrzeuge es sind,
wir verstehen, wie viel
schweres Gerät vorhanden ist,
wo es stehen kann,
wohin es fahren könnte,
und wo sie uns etwas Schlechtes
anrichten können.
Der Panzer selbst wird nicht weit kommen.
Er braucht Munition, er braucht Treibstoff,
viel Treibstoff.
Das heißt, die ganze Kolonne
zieht hinter ihm her.
Neben dem Panzer gibt es immer
irgendwelche Infanterie zur Deckung.
Wohin sie fahren,
bis wohin sie kommen können,
wo könnten sie sich aufhalten?
Und wo sie dann anhalten,
kann unsere Artillerie sie
entsprechend empfangen.
Ein großer Verdienst ist der territorialen
Verteidigung zuzuschreiben.
Manche sagen, dass sie nichts getan haben,
dass sie bloss rumstanden.
Ja, es mag Einzelfälle gegeben haben,
in denen die Jungen etwas
in der Stadt bewachten,
aber die Stadtbewohner sahen ja nicht,
was sich am Stadtrand abspielte
und wer wirklich auf den Feind traf.
Aber na ja, das sind nur Worte.
— Ja. Menschen beurteilen andere gerne.
— Natürlich. Stets.
Am ersten Tag, als wir am Sammelplatz waren,
hat man nach den Waffen gefragt,
nach der Ausrüstung,
von Lebensmitteln war keine Rede.
Auf dem Einberufungszettel stand außerdem,
dass man für eine bestimmte Zeit
Essen mitbringen soll.
Solange man am Sammelpunkt
nicht für Essen sorgt,
helfen kümmern sich die Einheimischen:
Tee, Kaffee, selbstgemachte Teigwaren.
Dann haben wir Nudeln gekocht
und Kartoffelpüree gemacht.
Das sind Ukrainer.
Im Prinzip war niemand überrascht,
aber allen hat diese Hilfe echt gut getan.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ein Junge kommt
und einen Armeeangehörigen sieht,
sagt er: “Ruhm der Ukraine!“
Ganz kleine Kinder.
Das ist eindrucksvoll und wir stehen dafür.
Hier sind wir am Rande
unserer Umgehungsstraße.
Unsere Jungs kamen
vom ersten Tag an hierher.
Unter uns nennen wir diesen Ort „Sparta”.
Das ist unser „Sparta”.
Heldenhafte Jungs, Helden.
— „Dreihundert Spartaner“?
—Nein, hier waren es deutlich weniger.
Aber sie haben durchgehalten,
und der Feind war etwa 600-700 Meter
von hier entfernt,
und wenn man noch weiter geht —
400 Meter von hier,
da stand bereits die feindliche Technik.
— Wie konnte man die Russen hier aufhalten?
— Wie... Durch den Willen Gottes und nach Plan.
Wohin würden wir denn zurücktreten?
Nur in die Stadt.
Und in der Stadt waren Kinder, Frauen, Eltern.
Man hat sie nicht in die Stadt
reinlassen dürfen.
— Was ist mit den Gefangenen hier?
— Mit unseren oder mit denen?
— Mit denen.
— Man hat Gefangene genommen.
— Wie ist es passiert?
— Fragen Sie diejenigen,
die sie genommen haben.
Solche Geheimnisse
darf man nicht verraten.
Die Russen haben Fachleute.
Es gab auch Burjaten
und slawische Gesichter,
und die russische Garde war hier.
Aber es gab wahre Fachleute, sie kamen
und richteten großen Schaden an.
Wir verfügen aber auch über
eigene Fachmänner.
Unsere Jungs haben gut gearbeitet.
Es hat geholfen, dass unser Bürgermeister
zu Beginn des Krieges sagte,
dass es für jeden Gefangenen
300 Dollar geben wird.
Verbrannter Schützenpanzer —
200.000 Hrywnja (ca. 5000 EUR)
Ausgebrannter Panzer —
250.000 Hrywnja (ca. 6200 EUR)
Gefangene oder getötete
russische Faschisten
Besatzer — 300 USD pro Person.
Unsere Jungs haben damit
etwas Geld verdient.
Sozusagen Gastarbeiter.
Wer auch immer kann, hilft bei der
Verteidigung unseres Heimatlandes.
Die Stadtwerke waren immer im Dienst,
sie haben sicherlich nicht weniger geleistet
als die Verteidiger.
Gibt es ein Beschuss oder nicht —
Wasser, Strom, Gas, Gruben...
Das sind Ukrainer, das sind echte Ukrainer.
So sieht ihrer Meinung nach
eine „russische Welt“ aus.
Zerquetscht, verbrannt, zerschlagen.
Anscheinend sind sie daran gewöhnt.
Ich glaube, das ist Neid.
Sie können bei ihnen nichts besser machen,
sie tun nur alles, damit es ihren Nachbarn
schlechter geht als ihnen selbst.
— Ich war am 25. Februar hier.
— Ist hier alles passiert?
— Nein, es war damals noch unversehrt,
erst danach wurde es bombardiert.
Ich war drinnen.
Der Ladenchef gab die Erlaubnis,
Säcke, Schaufeln und
alles Nötige mitzubringen,
um die Stellungen auszurüsten.
Wir sind hierher gekommen.
Wir gingen hinein
die Sicherheitsleute haben schon
etwas vorbereitet.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt began bereits der Beschuss
und die Decke begann einzustürzen.
Da fühlt man sich ein wenig in Gefahr,
wenn die Decke auf einen fällt.
Wir gingen raus und als wir es taten,
drehe ich mich um, schau hin:
die feindliche Infanterie war bereits
vor diesen Häusern.
Und von dort aus kam der Panzer T-72.
Sie kamen hierhin mit dem Gedanken,
dass sie hier mit Blumen empfangen würden.
Sie suchten nach den Blumen.
Wir haben uns, sozusagen, taktisch
zurückgezogen, alles ist uns gelungen.
Ich bin dennoch zurück in den Laden gelaufen,
weil die Jungs ein paar Zigarettenschateln
für mich gesammelt haben.
Wie soll es denn ohne Zigaretten gehen?
Als ich das sah, ging ich
zurück in den Laden,
nahm die Zigaretten und wir fuhren los.
Die Russen waren in Überzahl
und mit schwerem Gerät.
Wir waren nur zu dritt mit Schusswaffen,
das heißt,wir hatten keine Chancen.
Und als ich bei unserem Stützpunkt ankam,
erfuhr ich bereits,
dass dieser Panzer angehalten wurden,
einer getroffen wurde und
der andere weggezogen war.
Die Infanterie zieht sich zurück.
Und dann versammelten sich zwei LKWs,
es waren viele Freiwillige da drin.
Mit Waffen und dem Ruf „Tod dem Feind!“
Sie fuhren hin, machen Räumungsoperationen,
damit keiner da rumläuft.
Das heißt, die Russen kamen hierher
mit freudiger Stimmung,
wurden sehr „warmherzig“ empfangen
und kamen nie wieder  zurück.
Aber ständig, jeden Tag,
während die Stadt umzingelt war,
während die Kämpfe umherum stattfanden,
wurden tagtäglich Raketen abgefeuert.
Entweder am zweiten oder dritten Tag,
Ende Februar — Anfang März,
war es hier vollständig verbrannt.
Es tut mir für die Leute leid.
Dort stehen schon Neubauten,
die die Menschen für sich
selbst gekauft haben,
es wurde noch nicht genehmigt,
aber bereits vernichtet.
Ich denke, dass all dies im Laufe der Zeit
nach und nach wiederhergestellt wird.
Russland ist ein großes Land,
es verfügt über viele Ressourcen.
Auch über die Arbeitskräfte.
Obwohl wir ihre Arbeitskräfte
wahrscheinlich nicht brauchen —
wir haben unsere eigenen
fleißigen Menschen.
— Was ist das für ein Haus?
— Dieses Haus... Ich habe es schon
in diesem Zustand gesehen,
eine ältere Frau lebte hier, sie hat überlebt,
sie war zu Hause.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Glück sie hatte,
wer sie gerettet hat.
Ein Schutzengel oder noch etwas.
Die Explosion schleuderte sie unter das Bett.
Und so blieb sie am Leben.
So sieht unsere Ukraine jetzt aus,
glaube ich.
Es gibt keine Wand, kein Dach,
aber die Erinnerung ist drin.
Und das alles wird fortbestehen,
das ist sicher.
Als wir heute um das ehemalige Kino,
heute – Jugendzentrum, spazierten,
in dem eine Fliegerbombe einschlug,
haben die Menschen da
das Dach neugedeckt.
Die Menschen pflegen ihre
eigenen kleinen Gärten
in der Nähe von Hochhäusern,
einfach in der Stadt.
Wer hat jetzt die Zeit und Gelegenheit dazu,
jeder versucht, die Situation
auf seine Weise zu lösen,
die Stadt irgendwie auf seine Art
schöner und lebenswerter zu machen.
Ich erinnere mich, als ich gepostet habe,
dass wir diese Reise machen würden,
sagten ein paar Leute:
„Oh mein Gott, oh mein Gott,
nehmen Sie vier Ersatzreifen mit, denn sie
werden ständig platte Reifen haben”.
Aber nichts dergleichen ist passiert.
Obwohl es an den Straßenrändern sowieso
viele kaputte Militärtechnik gibt,
und im Allgemeinen ist vieles kaputt.
Die letzten Tage verbrachten wir
in Tschernihiw,
und es scheint mir, dass es in Tschernihiw
möglich wäre, darüber zu filmen,
wie Menschen halfen und
wie die Stadt sich vereinte.
Das könnte wochenlang gefilmt werden.
Und wir konnten nur einen kleinen Teil zeigen,
von dem, was dort geschah,
und von den verschiedenen Initiativen,
die sich in dieser Zeit dort gebildet haben.
Es ist sehr cool, dass die Menschen
jetzt über „wärmere“
und effektive Kontakte verfügen.
Das heißt, diejenigen, die in Tschernihiw
geblieben sind,
haben sich zu einem
großen Netzwerk entwickelt.
Und das wird meiner Meinung nach
in der Zukunft viele Städte ändern,
die den Krieg überlebt haben.
Es wird sowohl die Machthabenden, als auch
die Einstellung gegenüber ihnen ändern.
Denn ich denke, dass die Menschen
in solchen Situationen das Gefühl haben,
dass sie alle direkt die Macht sind.
Und das ist meiner Meinung nach
die wichtigste Veränderung,
die vielen Städten und Dörfern
der Ukraine bevorsteht.
Weil die Dezentralisierungsreform bereits
vor fünf oder mehr Jahren stattfand,
aber immer noch verstehen viele Leute nicht,
wie es funktioniert
und dass jeder von uns
ein Teil dieser Macht ist.
Aber so ist es.
[Übersetzer
Semen Pavlenko]